my name is Casey Langan I'm a software
engineer for amazon.com and I wrote the
Amazon mp3 store app for Android let me
show you how it works
so you'll notice on the home screen
there's easy access to all the major
features there are the top 100 albums
top 100 songs these are updated hourly
you can browse by genre or you can
search and searches what I'll demo for
you today so I'm going to tap the search
button and I'm going to select Hendrix I
want to look at some Jimi Hendrix albums
I am interested in printing this blues
album so I'm going to tap it I'll be
presented with an album detail page
which contains all the tracks on the
album I can scroll around in here and
preview tracks in place so I can just
tap moudou child blues okay I like the
song so I'm gonna go ahead sit so I'm
going to press this price button I will
tap again to confirm as soon as the
purchase completes my downloads to be
queued and I'll be presented with this
download screen and as soon as this
track finishes downloading it'll be
automatically added to the music app so
select albums notice here's the blues
album and here's a blowjob loose so
that's how use the Amazon mp3 store app
Amazon is really interested in reaching
as many people on as many different
platforms as possible so the move to the
mobile market seemed very logical
Android made that really easy we use the
Apache HTTP client to download metadata
from our web services we use make
extensive use of the ListView
and in fact I think we use the ListView
in every activity in our application and
we also use the media player quite a bit
for song previews